don't challenge Asians because we will
pay at break records not like in sport
or anything in sports as well yeah which
ones gymnastic sometimes ice-skating
gymnastic sometimes skiing sometimes do
you ice china never see a Chinese
[ __ ] in Olympic [ __ ] do they do
any what do they do they win right who
the Chinese and why was it what's the
thing that would be gymnastics
gymnastics figure skating everything no
Koreans Koreans don't win anything you
know that don't they do the Winter
Olympics they destroy everyone this guy
at what at the the inline the skating
competition what are you called Oh with
a pole oh no he's Japanese in the Merisi
I'm Cassie setting yourself back poor
guy son why not the greatest snowboarder
of all what are you saying I haven't had
a we have Annette achievements in
red-headed culture is that we trying to
say achievements of ready to call
president of the United States
Trotta best trip best president of all
time that's true he's ours
yeah Ron Howard o national [ __ ]
treasure yeah Bob yeah Robert Redford
he's ransom yeah you wanna keep on
Lucille [ __ ] ball the seal legend
you're right you're right
you only keep going because I can't I
got a list of my people yeah the actors
actors what else do you want the Koreans
are ahead in cloning tech time okay Oh
on sports in sports ready to sports the
white mamba play for the Celtics retired
now Scout by Brian Scalabrine
yeah it's Chloe Kim Canelo looks exactly
like me
every time I do Joe Rogan somebody goes
cool to see Canelo on broke but heavier
is a slew of redheads I've couldn't get
no respect but why do redheads go into
comedy there's a lot of you now the most
famous red the most famous redheads are
Koreans the most famous some of the most
famous comedians all right yeah Conan
O'Brien Louie CK ready uh level up Bill
burr bill burr me I'm not even in that
category but well one day I will be
known as Lucille Ball is unequivocally
one of the greatest female comedians in
the history of invention of yaumatei
yeah yeah she is the beginning yeah uh
who else is a gorilla's or ahead to
Richard Pryor we need he turned to the
ghostwriter for a second and burr two of
the greatest comics of all time redheads
yeah you're right
redheads get into comedy redheads I'll
tell you why though I think it was
backer there you go
I asked for his record I think it has to
do with a lot of like Koreans and a lot
of people that were like bullied or they
had traumatic childhoods and stuff hmm a
lot of us go into comedy I think there
is a correlation between being a redhead
a person and being funny
[Music]